The personnel of the SCP Foundation are proud,
highly-trained professionals.
They are selected from the best of the best
from universities and militaries across the
world.
The researchers, agents, and soldiers that
do the daily work of securing, containing,
and protecting the world from anomalies, take
their duties very seriously.
When the fate of millions potentially relies
on your daily decision-making, things can
be a little intense to say the least.
Kind of makes you want to take back that old
Uber driving gig now doesn’t it?
But with the massive amounts of personnel
the Foundation hires, it’s inevitable that
not every employee lives up to this high standard.
In fact, sometimes they purposefully subvert
the standard.
Whether it be for personal gain, power, or
something else entirely, the consequences
of exploiting their position is often disastrous.
SCP-321 is living - if you can call it that
- evidence of one such incident.
The file itself is heavily classified - in
fact, it’s been personally redacted by O5-12,
one of the thirteen mysterious Overseers that
control the day-to-day operations of the Foundation.
As for why… that will eventually become
clear.
In fact, it’s so heavily classified and
hidden from main Foundation servers that it
isn’t even possible to show it here in its
full state.
But that doesn’t matter, anyway - because
SCP-321 isn’t the kind of thing you can
read.
It’s so visceral, you need to see it to
believe it.
So put on your lab coat and get your clearance
card.
We’re going down into the bowels of Site-04
to find out just what this strange anomaly
is that an Overseer is so insistent on hiding
from the world.
Imagine you’ve been working at the Foundation
for several years.
You’ve seen all the famous anomalies.
You’ve taken tissue samples from SCP-682,
you’ve conducted material tests with SCP-914
and you’ve even interviewed SCP-049.
All the other researchers have shown you the
ropes but you’ve more than surpassed them.
Your superiors have taken notice that you
have a good, clean track record with intelligent
and humanoid anomalies.
You’ve recently been promoted from Junior
Researcher to a full-fledged Foundation Researcher,
and your clearance class has gone up.
You can now access files for most anomalies
in the course of your duties.
But working at the SCP Foundation isn’t
all fun and games.
There’s a whole lot of paperwork to fill
out.
Paperwork for tests, paperwork for new anomalies,
paperwork for every little containment update
whether it be a dietary change or completely
altering an anomaly’s containment method.
You spend long, long hours between meetings
or tests in your office at your Foundation-issue
terminal, poring over SCP files and documents
to print out or put together briefings on.
During one of these late-night work sessions,
having gone down a rabbit hole into SCPs filed
under ‘reanimation’ and ‘humanoid’
tags, you encounter a hyperlink to the file
for SCP-321.
Mildly intrigued at the memorable number,
you click it - only to be caught off guard
entirely when your terminal freezes up.
The screen locks up, and a single message
flashes on the screen: “UNAUTHORIZED ACCESS!
AUTOMATICALLY SHUTTING DOWN!”.
The machine reboots itself and seems fine,
but you’re startled by the experience.
Though obviously it’s not unheard of - sometimes
documents in the Foundation are just locked
up and people forget to make note of it.
This SCP-321 must be just another file, nothing
to worry about.
You know that, but that doesn’t stop you
from sleeping with the lights on in your dormitory
that night.
The next morning when you report the incident
to your supervisor she seems disinterested.
She assures you it was just a minor unauthorized
access hiccup, it happens all the time within
the database.
But when she asks you what file it was out
of curiosity and you respond with the number
SCP-321 - well, her response is… odd.
She quietly writes something down, muttering
something about “Adam”, and curtly dismisses
you to get back to work.
It’s a curious mystery, but it stays a mystery,
and you don’t hear about SCP-321 again for
a long time.
It’s years later.
You’ve participated in hundreds more research
inquiries and thousands of tests and experiments
since.
Your skill with anomalies is pretty notable
in Site-04 now, and you stand out in a crowd.
Your position rises appropriately - congratulations!
You’ve made Senior Researcher.
Very few ever get to this position, much less
at your age.
You supervise research over dozens of anomalies
and over a hundred staff.
Though you don’t do much testing with your
own hands anymore.
It’s too risky to send Senior Researchers
in for grunt work, and your role is mostly
one of oversight and supervising.
So when you receive an email one late night
on your terminal for containment procedures
of some anomaly you’ve never heard of, you’re
not too surprised.
But when you read the subject line, that changes.
SCP-321.
The same mysterious anomaly that nearly bricked
your terminal when you were just a researcher.
You’re now about to find out what was so
secret that it needed to be restricted so
heavily.
You click the email, holding your breath and
find Nothing.
No description of the anomaly, no addendums,
and certainly no images or supplements.
Just a partially filled out SCP document.
Item number 3890, object class safe.
All that’s there is a sparse set of containment
procedures:
“SCP-321 is to be kept in a regulation containment
chamber.
SCP-321 has been outfitted with extensive
braces, to make up for weaknesses in bone
structure and muscle mass.
Its artificial heart is to be examined once
a month for any damage.
SCP-321 is to be fed three times daily.
Solid foods are excluded from its prescribed
diet.
Three staff members are on temporary SCP-321
assignment at this time.
SCP-321 is to be given three hours a day of
exercise and physical therapy, with the rest
of its time not involved in experiments to
be confined to its cell.
While SCP-321 is incapable of asking for anything,
it has been allowed several stuffed toys.”
Very, very strange.
It seems to be some kind of humanoid anomaly,
but it’s not clear whether its sentient
or not.
It also seems remarkably fragile - with all
sorts of medical shunts and splints to counteract
extensive calcium deficiency in the bones
and atrophied muscles.
And an artificial heart?
Lots of resources are being spent on keeping
this thing - whatever it is - alive.
But what kind of a life does it live, not
even being able to eat properly and needing
constant physical therapy between experiments.
The stuffed animals thing is even more haunting.
Stuffed animals are something the Foundation
tends to reserve for child anomalies.
And why can’t it request anything?
All you can conclude is that the Foundation
is, for whatever reason, keeping a fragile
mute child in the maximum security wing of
Site-04 and not letting anyone know about
it.
It’s not a pleasant thought, but you know
that these things aren’t done for no reason.
Whatever this anomaly is, it likely poses
a danger to itself or people around it, and
needs this level of security.
You approve the containment procedures, close
your email, and go to sleep.
And once again, that’s all you hear of SCP-321,
whatever it is, for a very long time.
Site Director is an incredibly prestigious
position in the Foundation.
These titans manage massive Foundation installations
and facilities - they’re the executives,
the big-shots, the decision-makers.
Where the buck stops.
Some maintain the researcher roots they came
from and others fall fully into the role of
power player in the Foundation’s complicated
internal politics.
Either way, it’s a very high level of power
most people never get anywhere near.
When you’re made Assistant Site Director,
you know it’s not the real thing and that
getting up there is still a few years off.
But that doesn’t stop you from feeling incredibly
proud of how far you’ve come in your career
at the Foundation, how many breaches you’ve
stopped and lives you’ve saved by keeping
dangerous anomalies locked up.
You can access the full database file on nearly
every SCP in the site’s catalogue now.
It doesn’t take long before you think back
to the strange anomaly that had repeatedly
cropped up in your career and decide to now
bury the mystery.
You check in with your credentials and navigate
to the SCP-321 file to see what’s what.
It’s just your luck that the database file
is completely empty!
All that’s there are the same containment
procedures you authorized so many years ago
and a short message from RAISA - that the
SCP-321 file hasn’t been digitized yet and
that a physical copy is available in SCP-321’s
containment chamber.
Strange, but at least now you have somewhere
to go.
SCP-321’s chamber is deep, deep below Site-04.
It takes you three elevators and security
checkpoints to even get down there.
This is where the top-secret anomalies are
kept - not necessarily dangerous, but things
the Foundation would prefer not get out to
even their own employees.
It’s a dark hallway lined with steel doors.
You find the right door and scan your card,
and a guard waves you in.
You’re in an observation room of some kind,
with one large window looking out into an
adjoining containment chamber.
There’s computer screens all over the walls,
displaying medical information and data.
There’s no one else in the room, but something
is lying in the hospital bed in the containment
chamber.
There’s a clipboard hanging from the wall,
bearing the designation “SCP-321”.
You pick it up and carry it with you as you
enter the containment chamber and approach
the hospital bed.
SCP-321 lies in the bed.
It’s a long, distended looking humanoid
- almost 10 feet in length but incredibly
thin and frail looking.
It’s hair is thinning and the skin is taut
around its face but you can discern some decidedly
feminine-looking features.
Its eyes are closed - the thing is asleep,
and you give it a closer look as you cross-check
it with its documentation.
“SCP-321 is a human female, born some time
in the 1800s.
SCP-321 is currently 3.1 meters tall, and
weighs approximately 110 kilograms.
Subject is devoid of melanins in hair, eyes,
and skin.”
Yep, that checks out.
The anomaly is white as a ghost.
The document says that it can’t speak and
seems to have trouble with spatial recognition,
intelligence, and awareness, like a child.
Then it hits you - this thing must be from
the 19th century.
The next paragraph is redacted, but the one
after that is fascinating.
You look at it as you circle SCP-321’s bed.
It has complex regeneration abilities, and
is capable of healing injuries and wounds
five times faster than a normal person.
It ages incredibly slowly - which makes sense,
it should be dead by now if it was born well
over a century ago.
It’s noted down that its aging has stopped
entirely but it keeps growing taller and larger
despite being already over 10 feet tall, well
past the point where it’s heart should’ve
given out.
In fact, its heart did give out.
Somewhere in the 20th century, it became too
tall for its heart to properly circulate blood
to it.
This is the same condition that results in
genetic ‘giants’ dying so young.
But SCP-321 was restrained by the Foundation
to ensure blood kept flowing to its brain,
though this was a losing battle - its healing
factor was unable to repair tissue damage
happening constantly and in real time.
Decay and necrosis began to set in to its
muscles and organs.
The Foundation stepped in.
Just after World War 2, a team of researchers
began working to create a sort of artificial
heart that would allow SCP-321 to keep on
pumping blood.
Not too unlike the modern pacemaker device,
actually.
It was finished some years later and an expert-trained
team of Foundation surgeons were tasked with
implanting it.
Since they successfully completed the operation,
all of SCP-321’s internal damage has healed
perfectly.
More test revealed that its remarkable recuperative
abilities came from an abundance of stem cells
after exposure to an anomaly after…
death?
You look back up at the thing, and back down.
Is this a practical joke of some kind?
You’ve seen stranger things than this but
still…
a zombie?
But it doesn’t seem to be a zombie, though
it is undead.
It’s still human, at least apparently - it’s
been taught to eat and play with some toys,
as well as exercise itself, though it took
researchers years to train it to do so.
They’ve also figured out that its vocal
chords are intact - but for whatever reason,
it can’t learn to speak, just crying and
babbling like an infant.
The remaining two paragraphs are under the
subheader “Origin”.
But they are again redacted in marker, and
attributed to the Office of O5-12.
For some reason where this strange undead
woman came from is a highly-guarded secret
that O5-12 doesn’t want getting out.
Very, very strange.
But ultimately this is all you can do, for
now.
Obviously this thing is eking out a pitiful
existence down here.
Who knows if its even self-conscious?
If it can feel pain?
It’s unfortunate and depressing but after
so many years in the upper echelons of the
Foundation’s research staff, you’ve seen
some terrible, terrible things.
This is very sad, but what can you do?
The heart monitor in the room continues beeping
as you hang up the clipboard in the observation
room and take your leave.
It really doesn’t surprise anyone when you
eventually become Site Director just a few
short years later.
You’re given a warm welcome into the new
job, but there’s really no time to relax
at all.
Running a Foundation site is busy work.
Lots of meetings and important briefings to
be had - which is how you find yourself heading
to a meeting in the site with O5-12.
One of the strange, mysterious O5s that rule
the Foundation with an iron fist, subject
to no one but the Ethics Committee - what
could he possibly want with you?
Not to mention the fact that this meeting
is in none other than SCP-321’s containment
chamber.
When you arrive, you catch a glance of him.
He’s an incredibly old-looking man, healthy
but leaning on a cane.
You make small talk for a moment before he
starts talking about the anomaly lying in
the hospital bed in front of you two.
He explains that over a century ago, a Foundation
Junior Researcher named Adam had developed
a relationship with one of his colleagues,
a doctor named Evelyn.
The rules regarding relationships between
coworkers were much looser then, and they
married each other not long after.
They even had a child together - at least,
they were going to.
Unfortunately, tragedy struck not long after
Evelyn became pregnant.
The infant didn’t make it, and was stillborn.
But Adam, unwilling to give up, began to conduct
experiments on the corpse.
Using SCP-590, another one of Adam's anomalous
children named TJ, and a number of other SCPs,
he somehow managed to bring what remained
of his daughter back to life.
Well, to something resembling life - but the
Foundation quickly intervened when they discovered
what Adam had created.
They collected the creature and began to examine
and experiment on her, which is when they
discovered her amazing ability to heal from
practically any wound.
She was quickly classified SCP-321 and placed
into containment for experimentation.
But Adam was still a Junior Researcher at
the Foundation, and he knew his daughter was
undergoing cruel and invasive experimentation.
He couldn’t live with the guilt - first
of losing his wife, then his daughter.
He made several formal requests for SCP-321
to be removed from SCP status on the basis
that it was unnecessary.
All were denied by the O5 Council.
Years later, Adam had been promoted to Personnel
Director at Site-04.
He again requested SCP-321 be released from
containment, and was again given a firm no.
But a father’s love never goes away.
As he kept being promoted, he kept requesting
his daughter be freed into his custody.
When he became Site Director of Site-04, just
as you had joined the Foundation, he made
a statement declaring that there was nothing
more the Foundation had to learn from SCP-321
and that it should be released.
But again, nothing but denial.
And when he was promoted to O5-12, he ordered
that SCP-321 be released and returned to her
family.
That’s right - O5-12, the old man standing
beside you, is the same man that fathered
and created SCP-321 so many years ago.
And that’s not all, either.
His name is Adam Bright - father of notorious
researcher Doctor Jack Bright, otherwise known
as SCP-963.
The Bright family’s history is intertwined
with that of the SCP Foundation, but despite
all their power, they cannot get one of their
own released from the Foundation’s cells.
When O5-12 made the decree, O5-1 addressed
him personally.
He was told that SCP-321 was not his daughter,
if she ever had been.
And that if he requested her release again,
he would be dismissed from the O5 Council.
Since then, all he has been able to do is
visit his little girl deep beneath Site-04
and protect her from further experimentation.
He explains that he hides and classifies her
existence so heavily to make sure no one tries
to perform more tests and take advantage of
her healing factor.
That’s why you were unable to access or
even figure out what the anomaly was for so
many years.
All the two of you can do is stand next to
the hospital bed.
The history of the SCP Foundation is a long
and twisted one, especially considering the
complex web of relationship between its employees.
The extensive Bright family, headed by famous
Jack Bright but containing many of his relatives,
winds throughout the Foundation.
When one of its members abuses their position,
you’ve seen how terrible the results can
be.
As for SCP-321, some anomalies tragically
can’t be saved, and there’s little the
Foundation can do about that.
Now go check out “SCP Immortal Dr. Bright
Explained” and “DR.
BRIGHT FOR PRESIDENT SCP-4444 - Bush v. Gore”
for more on the fascinating intricacies of
the infamous Dr. Jack Bright!